on march 16 1957 at eight o'clock in the
morning a 300-foot long spacecraft
landed in a field in alexandria virginia
two local police officers arrived on the
scene the door of the craft slowly
opened the officers drew their guns not
sure what to expect to their surprise
out walked a normal looking guy he
smiled at the stunned officers and
actually waved hello and before the
policeman could say a word the stranger
said in clear english i need to see the
president nine months after this event
nasa was founded this is the story of
what happened in between this is the
story of valiant thor and if you don't
know this one hold on tight we're going
on a hell of a ride
in the fall of 1957 the soviet union
launched sputnik 1 and 2 the first
man-made satellites to go into orbit
this caught the united states off guard
the american population was terrified
that the russians could launch an attack
from space the american military was
embarrassed that russia's superior
technology president eisenhower demanded
action on january 31 1958 the united
states responded by attempting to launch
the vanguard satellite attempting uh it
exploded shortly after takeoff oh boy
the space race was not going well for
the americans the president asked
congress to establish an agency to
direct american activities in space and
in july of that year nasa was created
although the russians had more space
achievements for the next few years it
didn't take long for the u.s to catch up
with and surpass the soviet union this
couldn't have been done without nasa and
the leaps forward in technology that
nasa provided nasa helped create velcro
freeze drying foam mattresses solar
cells smartphone cameras even the
bowflex nasa owns over 2600 patents and
is credited with over 2 000 commercial
products derived from their technology
and these nasa provided leaps forward
happen fast a more suspicious person
might say they happened a little too
fast the story of valiant thor might
provide a few answers valiant thor a man
from another world agreed to share the
technology of his people with the united
states
but valiant thor would want something in
return
on the morning of march 16 1957 harley
andrew byrd the nephew of the legendary
admiral richard bird is in his office at
the pentagon and he's a high-ranking
official working for project blue book
the top secret military program that
studied ufos from 1952 to 1969. around 8
30 a.m bird receives a panicked call
from the alexandria police department
officers are on their way to the
pentagon right now with a visitor that's
an understatement a few minutes later
the police car pulled up to the pentagon
the secretary of defense charles wilson
and six of his staff are there to meet
the stranger
out of the car steps a tall man with
brown hair and an easy going manner he
looks completely normal except he's
wearing a silver and gold jumpsuit you
like elvis
the stranger is ushered into an elevator
that goes to the basement of the
pentagon and from there an underground
train takes the group of men to the
white house they're taken directly to
the oval office where president
eisenhower is waiting the president
asked the stranger his name
valiant he replies or val
where do you come from val eisenhower
asks i come from the planet your bible
calls the morning and evening star
venus asked the president
yes sir eisenhower asked for proof and
val offers to show the president his
ship eisenhower asked that they sit and
talk for a while first val says that
earth has been quietly observed for
thousands of years but with the
invention of the atomic bomb val's
people decided to intervene val was sent
by the high council which represents a
governing body that spans many planets
and many intelligent species kind of
like the star trek federation val says
the high council can help solve a lot of
the earth's problems and is offering
assistance the president asked val to
stay at the pentagon as his guest and
val agrees the president also asked val
to join him at a meeting at howard
menger's house in highbridge new jersey
now this was a small gathering of
researchers and scientists who advised
the president on ufo matters val again
agrees he would also like to bring along
the rest of his crew and at that meeting
something unexpected happened but we're
very fortunate that it did a young air
force photographer named august roberts
took pictures of val and his crew
[Music]
since val and his crew would be wearing
normal human clothes for the meeting the
military wanted to examine and test the
spacesuit that he wore they called it
the miracle garment now though it had
fabric enough to cover a six foot tall
man it weighed only six ounces including
a pair of boots it was also
indestructible they shot it with guns
poured acid on it used a laser even a
diamond tip drill not only could they
not pierce the fabric they couldn't even
make a mark on it oh
hang on what you got pictures of aliens
but you want to talk about fabric i'm
just giving background and you wonder
why the algorithm hates the channel this
is why get to the weird stuff fine
these are the pictures taken at howard
menger's house at the meeting in
highbridge new jersey
these are photos of val and the other
members of his crew don jill and tanya
those names don't sound very venetian
venusian what'd i say at this meeting
val told the president how they could
help solve world hunger cure disease and
end all war but they needed all
countries with nuclear weapons to disarm
eisenhower politely said that mankind
just wasn't ready for such drastic
changes that's when val realized he
couldn't accomplish his mission alone he
needed someone from earth who was
open-minded to help him convince the
leaders of the world that person would
spend the next three years working
closely with valiant thor and his name
was dr frank strange's
dr frank stranges was a well-known ufo
researcher author and theologian he had
phd's in psychology philosophy and
criminology one day frank receives a
call from a very excited august roberts
the photographer at the highbridge
gathering he got these photos of aliens
but doesn't know what to do with them
frank is fascinated by the photos and
starts using them in his lectures after
giving a talk in washington dc frank is
signing copies of his books and chatting
with guests a woman introduces herself
as nancy warren she looks around and
while holding up a pentagon id card she
quietly asks if frank wants to meet the
man in those pictures
of course he jumps at the chance and the
next morning frank arrives at the
pentagon and is taken to val's quarters
the door opens val extends his hand
gives a warm smile and says hello frank
val knows everything about him they chat
for a while and val says he needs
frank's help frank wants to know why he
of all people gets this honor val says
that frank had an open mind was
constantly talking to people and was
also a minister of the gospel of jesus
christ i'm gonna have to stop you right
here
how did we get from venus to jesus well
frank strange's was a christian
evangelist he preached that jesus and
the angels are actually
extraterrestrials and there are
references to ufos in the bible
got anything else uh no uh this
this story is
wow uh
well let me uh you know what i
i better wait just just keep going so
valiant thor's mission is to save
mankind specifically to help mankind
return to god
val asks frank to help spread this
message in exchange val will share all
the wonders of the universe with the
human race though this meeting is a
short one val reveals a lot of
information he confirms that there is
intelligent life on other planets many
other planets and there are more solar
systems in the universe than we could
even dream of and over the next few
years
val works with the united states
government and agrees to share some of
his technology nasa right and valiant
thor's mission officially begins
[Music]
as the years went on val confided in
frank strange's about some of the
extraterrestrial activity happening on
earth
well there are communication devices
hidden in homes around the world and
today some of these homes are in reno
san diego los angeles and geneva and the
equipment is a holographic communicator
whoever you're speaking with appears to
be in the same physical room as you are
and frank saw one of these devices in
use and couldn't believe it this
equipment allows communication between
bases on earth between ships and with
the home-based ship that's orbiting the
planet and during this time val's work
with president eisenhower is not going
well a few times val convinces the
president to convene a meeting of the
united nations to begin the process of
earth joining the intergalactic
community but every time this comes
close to happening the cia or department
of defense interferes they fear that if
val's message gets out too many people
will follow it and this would threaten
america's military supremacy and they
shut the president down and president
eisenhower actually gave us a hint that
this was happening in his farewell
address in 1961 just a year after val's
mission ends eisenhower warns against
the establishment of a military
industrial complex and that creating a
weapons industry would be dangerous that
they would become too rich and too
powerful yeah he was right on the money
with that one he sure was and remember
eisenhower was the armiest army guy on
the planet he was the supreme commander
of the allied forces in world war ii he
was elected president because he was a
war hero but here he was saying we can't
allow weapons and war to become a
profitable business and colleagues of
eisenhower like general macarthur
thought this speech was crazy especially
with the soviet union becoming so
powerful but ike meant it i like ike
yeah they don't make them like that
anymore so val's three-year mission came
to an end in 1960 and was not a success
but that wouldn't be the last time we
hear from valiant thor
[Music]
even though his relationship with val
changed his life for the better frank
strange's experiences weren't all
positive after giving a lecture in
germany his food was poisoned and he
nearly died val appeared with the
antidote and a warning for frank watch
your back a few years later frank is on
his way to meet val when he shoved in
the back of a car he's taken out to the
desert and nearly beaten to death until
val and don show up and on his honeymoon
frank and his wife are run off the road
by a mysterious black car frank's neck
and hips are broken he almost dies in
the hospital but val shows up and heals
him instantly he walked out of the
hospital that day in perfect health but
the most important event in frank's life
happened in june 1968. val tells frank
to fly to san diego there's something he
needs to see battle picks up frank in
the airport and they drive southward
mexico across the border and finally
stop at a little town called san felipe
they park the car behind a restaurant
and walk a rocky path down to the beach
and that's when frank saw it
a 300 foot long 21 foot tall silver
saucer hovering just on top of the water
val looked at frank pointed at the
spacecraft and asked wanna see
[Music]
the interior of the spaceship is
enormous it doesn't look scientific more
like a resort there's a library a gym
dining hall and media rooms after
getting a tour frank is shown to his
room he says the floor feels like a
thick cloud and with every step the
surface conforms to the shape of his
foot
there are no corners or right angles
anywhere everything feels organic and
peaceful frank settles in and has one of
the most restful nights of sleep of his
entire life in the morning val takes
frank back to the san diego airport as
the years pass
frank adds these experiences to his
lectures trying to spread val's message
and in 1967 he publishes the book
stranger at the pentagon which documents
all of frank's time with val now i'll
link to the book below you can buy it on
amazon but i'll also link to a place
where you can read it for free the book
has more pictures of val flying saucers
all kinds of strange things and frank
breaks down the technology that they
have types of propulsion anti-gravity
all kinds of stuff frank even includes a
diagram of the spaceship and though
frank strange has passed away a few
years ago valiant thor is still here as
we speak his ship victor one is parked
and cloaked on the shore of lake mead
east of vegas
and several thousand people are aware of
val and victor one including about 2 000
government employees a few scientists
have even been on board and the book
ends with a message from val in short he
says we should be kind to one another be
open-minded and spend more time in the
service of others treat people as you'd
like to be treated val is describing the
golden rule it's nice to know the golden
rule applies no matter what planet
you're on so if you're watching this and
have access to one of those
communication devices do us a favor and
let val know
we need him
more than ever
valiant thor is probably the most
requested topic on this channel and it's
easy to see why it's a story rich with
characters and action and a positive
message and here comes the butt he ruins
the story but is it true well let's
start with harley andrew byrd the man
working for project blue book at the
pentagon
he says he's admiral byrd's nephew i'll
post a link to admiral byrd's genealogy
below the admiral did have four nephews
none named harley andrew but could the
genealogy be wrong
sure
doubtful but it could be but if harley
really was in the pentagon in 1957
that would mean he had top secret
clearance
as a teenager
okay
another believer is laura eisenhower
great-granddaughter of the president
himself now she claims she was recruited
to go to mars in 2006 ufo disclosure is
coming and that valiant thor is real
but is she credible well that really
depends on your personal beliefs she's
an intuitive astrologist a global
alchemist cosmic mythologist a guardian
of the organic ascension timeline and an
opener of natural stargates it's a hell
of a resume yeah it's a lot
but if we really are in the danger that
she claims we need all the cosmic
warriors we can get but what about dr
frank stranges
here's where things get messy first of
all the entire story of valiant thor
comes from strange's book stranger at
the pentagon which was released in 1967
but val arrived 10 years earlier and
during that time frank published other
books on ufos and even produced a couple
of documentaries about ufos and aliens
no mention of valiant thor in all that
time well maybe he was waiting for the
right time to tell the story maybe but
we have to consider the messenger frank
claimed to have three phds from two
colleges well one of those colleges
doesn't exist and the other doesn't
offer phds and never has he says he was
the deputy director of the california
state marshal association but there's no
such thing the book itself is basically
a retelling of the day the earth stood
still i come in peace take me to your
leader nuclear weapons are bad the hero
and the alien become friends it's
exactly the same but frank made it very
very religious
everything in the book is god's will the
power of christ all that stuff but frank
was a preacher a christian evangelist so
this is to be expected he traveled the
country giving lectures about ufos and
their connection to god in the bible
stranger at the pentagon is a book about
spreading the word of christ if the
story isn't real this is a genius way to
get non-believers interested in
christianity adding aliens can improve
any story agreed what about the pictures
of the aliens i know it's real that i
don't know
they could be pictures of an alien crew
advising the president of the united
states or they could be pictures of
random people at a backyard barbecue
nobody's come forward claiming to know
anyone in the photos so we can't prove
them but we can't debunk them either and
look this story is way out there but in
the 40 years he spent giving lectures
about valiant thor frank's story never
wavered and ever since then many people
have sprung up claiming to know valiant
thor or even be valiant thor val has his
own author page on amazon so he writes
books now
now do i believe jesus was an alien
no do i believe the story of valiant
thor
not at all but
val's message of being kind and spending
more time in the service of one another
having an open mind these are things i
do believe in we all should and that's
the irony of the story the more you
ridicule valiant thor it turns out the
more you need him
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share i i
hate to give you
errands to run but that stuff really
helps the channel and this topic today
comes from you so if you'd like to
submit a topic go to
theywhyfiles.comtips
and put in whatever you like i can't do
every topic that comes in but i read
them all and special thanks to our
generous patrons who make this channel
possible i couldn't do this without you
so until next time be safe be kind and
know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you